une bagarre dans les marseillais yeux en
classe entre benjamin et tony et j'ai
pas qu'il est mais ils sont très sympas
il faut savoir c'est que benjamin est en
couple avec camille benjamin fall à
braga regardez ya une bagarre ababacar
fall et ses benjamins non il en double
avec cannes je suis qui fait la bague
exactions et la bagarre et toni n'est
autre que l'ex de camille bon leur
conquête pour la reconquérir
oka l'heure il est d'ailleurs allé la
voir pendant la nuit et ça n'a pas plu à
qui sa mère du coup la bagarre vous avez
dit qu'il voue à sa mère en fait vous
essayez d'être aussi drôle que c'est la
beauté nouvelle vidéo gag en direct tu
me connais pas je te connais pas mais un
conseil frimout la vie de ma mère me
roule pas ça parce que je remonte à
l'ère c'est pourquoi je te refais
l'espèce des foules avec son collègue à
la vitesse de fou alors choisir
dans cette émission c'est la seule
émission où des mecs sont brouillons
slip
non mais sans déconner quand tu es chez
toi moi je bois vert à droite parfois
s'ils pensent qu'ils imaginent monsieur
je dois aussi et j'imagine un
cambrioleur tu vois tu vas à l'épée
temps si c'est vrai tu m'as pas tant le
gâteau qu'est ce tu fais valeo va se
paie d'atheos malgache fait dire non
j'ai pas de détail kkr ne l'a jamais
laissé les rayons du savate habillé
apprend ça mais c'est vrai nom mais sans
révéler c'est un truc de ouf les dégâts
il sépare des mecs en slip avec une raie
apparente mais sans déconner ses bars
ses idées et des quais de la gare il est
rapide tous parce qu'il se trouvait que
ça à faire le buzz est rentré il veut
être à l'antenne qui sera excusé moi
mais je sais pas où tu deviens fou comme
ça mais non moins phrase 1,3 strike
d'en rajouter dans la rue à ce prix là
bas ça fait huit ans qu'il fait
l'émission s'il peut pas sortir trois
enfants alors être tous ses rideaux oui
madame
on parlera du un bout d'os après ça vous
plaît pas chut ressent peuvent
travailler dans une galerie ouais ça
fait un peu peur contemporains tels
bajac ouais merci
non mais tout ça pour vous dire qu'on en
fait même si tout ça est fake et
scénarisé écrit moi je trouve c'est un
très très mauvais exemple de relations
humaines et amoureuse pour les jeunes on
est forcément dans l'hystérie dans le
conflit tout le monde savait tout le
monde s'insulter je trouve que c'est
catastrophique et ravageur aujourd'hui
pour les rapports humains et les
rapports amoureux entre les valeurs
google ebooks et kelly qui est la plus
jeune de la bande est ce que vous suivez
encore les marseillais parce qu en
audience c'est plus ce que c'était
680 mille téléspectateurs mer c'est une
maison en face qu'ils font il faut les
records d'audience sur les 12 25 ans
notamment